[موسيقى]
التطورات السياسيه الى حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا رفضت موسكو اقتراح الرئيس
الاوكراني لودي ميرسي لاحلال السلام ولفت
المتحدث باسم الكرملين لانه ينبغي
لاوكرانيا ان تاخذ في الاعتبار الحقائق
التي استجدت على الارض وقدم الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي مقترحه الى زعماء الدولي
مجموعه السبع بعقد قمه سلاما عالميه في
فصل الشتاء تخصصه لاحلال السلام في
اوكرانيا وتركز القمه المقترحه على تنفيذ
خطه سلام من عشر نقاط وضعتها كيف تتضمنوا
التاكيد على سحب روسيا قوتها بالكامل من
اوكرانيا والا تقدمك اي تنازلات
المقترحه الاوكراني والرد الروسي جاء بين
منطلقت في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس اعماله
مؤتمرين لدعم اوكرانيا في المؤتمر الاول
الذي تشارك فيه نحو 70 دوله ومنظمه دوليه
الى تلبيه احتياجات اوكرانيا لتجاوز فصل
الشتاء بينما يركز المؤتمر الثاني وهو
ثنائي بين فرنسا واوكرانيا على مشاركه
الشركات الفرنسيه في اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا